oddio che brutta ma io sappia messi ma
penso tutti corretti che bella dentiera
devo formare un esercito di greymouth
sorpassare oggi giocheremo a tantissimi
giochi
qualora vi figlio di granny altri e
quindi tra super divertente vedere come
sono quasi giochi fake
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
poi lasciato un bel mi piace entro il 5
nei cambi 5 4 3 2 1 primo gioco che
proviamo si chiama ritz granny regni
ricca vediamo che cosa cambia da crimi
normale questa grendi fake che cosa di
diverso
innanzi tutto ok allora prendiamo già
foglietto con la cosa a casa sua casa
che vediamo un po come la casa
oddio che brutta faccia loro addio
istitutivo nel matrimonio
tutte elegante rosso e dorato però le
mancano ancora i capelli guardate
guardate un po come come stempiata quasi
aveva anche il trucco ebbene abbiamo già
perso una vita solo perché volevamo
guardare però ne è valsa la pena perché
abbiamo visto chiama granny ha ammesso
un parrucchino davanti è diventata
bellissima ho io non mi ricordo mai che
cosa bisogna fare in grembo però voglio
esplorare per prendere i soldi perché
ovviamente per granny ricca si sono i
pezzi di soldi guarda le poltrone le
sedie sono tipo il quale pareti sembrano
fatte di paglia però non troppo remoto
per essere d oro
vediamo come la macchina di creni ricca
vero aiuto deve domandare questa forte
che sa tutto sulla destra
carenza capitale perché vitale brevis
vivere riconosce gioca a memoria tutte
le volte che ho perso molte resi a
mattere granieri che abbiamo se mi
ricordo come se gioia dai vogliamo
vedere la macchina ricca di credi ricca
[Musica]
abbiamo solo due possibilità del giorno
sarà vitale secondo voi
facendo proprio da di topolino loggiato
arrivando a scappa siamo a vedere la
macchina di grande richiamo vediamo un
po alle roma sembra una macchina super
macro modello mi sembra diverso vediamo
il motore ancora d'oro
vediamo dietro ecco alcune indicazioni
ricca non cambia solamente perché è
tutto ricoperto di banconote erano di
all'improvviso prossimo gioco gioco ci
sono sia kranich aigrain fa quindi che
sarebbe il nord notte la ronda che il
nonno e sono tipo mezzo disegnati
sembrano bolt cattivi vediamo un po come
sono marino la sostanza meglio di
credenti questa tv ritiri
viti un po ci sarà qualcuno ci torno a
vedere qua ti sei nascosta secondo me le
cose niente però automatico nell'armadio
piccola arrivando qualcuno
ma no ma no veramente esiste capito i
passi che sono nascosta non sentono non
successive normative sente dei rumori
strani ma credo sia ancora fuori a far
ok ora possiamo uscire dalla porta
che cos'è il quale lo guarda una salsa
di pomodoro possa rompere il muro devo
trovare un giusto attrezzo carlino però
se ciò ho disegnato del problema finora
non si è visto il non facciamo nulla
possono se qualcuno
campolo grandissimo quest'asta questa
casa io è più grande di quella di cui
non puoi preparare le cose questo ciò
che sembra molto interessante
io ancora le chiavi in mano
provo a vedere se tutti qui perché il
tempo è brutto non si è bloccata seconda
[Musica]
cosa potrebbe premura che ora gioca
vitale io mi sono preso in parte del
nonno
arriviamo scende ragioni e si sono
trovati visto sotto al vestito di granny
non so se riuscirò dobbiamo andare un po
all'avventura
[Musica]
troppo né invece tante vite abbiamo mi
sa che ne sono rimaste solo due bene non
ce la farò mai
abbiamo giù a tempo per quasi nascondono
dubito che questo posto anche se
dovranno un primate faccia della camera
di sicurezza veramente adesso
arriveranno perché le camere che cosa
deve fare e deve scappare
ultima vita e mi sorge la farò io penso
di no non posso resistere
allora questa volta non andiamo nel
garage perché ci sono le camere
disponibilità quindi e niente o non
andate lì o chissà che apparteniamo
adesso questo lo vincerà il buco che si
sa bene di qua c'era uno sgabuzzino
però abbiamo bisogno di uno snack
speranza della band forse no forse la
puoi tirare tipo con il bidone quindi
devo per forza a scendere al piano di
sotto
sicuramente per me no non me lo dà
premio è il rapper qualcun altro ci
vuole un codice per aprire la porta e
non so con il codice
anima ma io tu sei più elegante mettere
il secondo il gioco fatti così
scriveteci nei commenti i vostri voti a
ogni gioco io primo gli do un
3 perché non era molto bello ma a questo
secondo gioco gli do un 8 9 perché è
molto bello voi che avete di date fate
ore al prossimo ragazzi forse abbiamo
sbagliato gioco non vi sembra gremi
questo però nell'immagine sir aggredì
vediamo che cosa ci aspettavamo che il
col de vars gioco perché c'era
l'immagine tigre ecco che allora vedete
questa è la schermata principale io ho
cliccato in questo brenni mod
non capisco perché il gioco non centrava
un bel niente
proviamo crazy brehme forse ok forse
questo full force vediamo ma io sono
gremio tutti gli altri sono granny ma
forse un gioco online ci sono anche gli
altri giocatori sembra tipo rublo cos'è
quel numero che si muove in quanto è
lontano grande forza eccola male ma chi
sono tutte queste come a qualcosa ci
hanno una mazza in mano a tempo la pulce
ramazza in mano
io sono grienti devo prendere io le
persone vanno in rete ma non trasformati
in grecia ma che adesso gli stanno
inseguendo
questi sono miei alleati ha detto
formare un esercito di grevy devono
fermare il nostro esercito dai alleati
gremi andate altri grilli
per una volta siamo noi g vedono capito
questa casa che cos'è ore di fila una
scuola la sim a scuola non ci sono altri
potenziali g e soprattutto come fanno
affermare ci deve essere qualche
giocatore che arriverà dire ok ho preso
di terni e tutti i suoi terni must ma
non c è più nessuno qua che cos'altro
devo fare con il mio esercito di grammi
ciascuna ruota
eccoli eccoli d'accordo ma dovete
proteste trasformato interessi mi chiedo
se c'è qualcun altro sono gli armadietti
perché l'ascoli trovate in g
[Musica]
sono arrivata terza
che voto date a questo gioco granny
robots in cui voi siete cremi scrivete
solo nei commenti io gli do un set da
era malato così alto che è ora proviamo
l'ultimo gioco e questo l'ultimo gioco
ma penso più però molto pauroso perché
c'è sarà irene
se non sapete chi è andate poi vedere
nel canale di vita l'abbiamo fatto un
gameplay con fire ed è quindi faccio che
si chiama siren premi dovrebbe esserci
siren ed al posto di grendi un regno
cosa instinet non otterrà un grande come
si vede tutto testa voglio riscriviamo
siren grendi sente tutto è passata
quindi devo scappare dalla casa non mi
dire che la solita casa di greg cambiato
l'arredamento vediamo un po come questo
arredamento allora quasi un quadro di
sanchez sarà il suo fidanzato
no penso e se non un nonno g è un vero è
se rabbia quasi un foglio bianco non
avevano voglia di vedere nessuna scritta
uscirò io non vedo l'ora di vedere come
è fatto questo grandi salire mente molto
verde qual cosa la so previsto si sono
gli shock per sparare tutto vediamo un
po come è stata la casa qua la sua
camera da letto è uguale praticamente
come sarà il bagno o no ho fatto rumore
si è caduto un appendiabiti mi dovrò
nascondere ma non c'è nessuno armadio
qua c'è qualcuno dietro ma che cos'è
questo rumore di macchina questo è il
bagno vediamo saint ed si lava la
partite non può entrare a contatto con
l'acqua altrimenti residui fulmine
ma in corso cecconi dai una cucina tesi
quadri che cosa mangerà sa niente della
felicità livide fili elettrici siete
possibili in ora non si vede le sanzioni
devono rivedere la macchina dei
saliranno dove si andava qua che vediamo
un po strana però ancora non è uscito
che cos'è ok ma devono essere qua la
macchina a macchina brutta e fatto
rumore nelle signora si è staccato il
paraurti sta arrivando e che è entrato
di nascosto in macchina non mi troverete
sicuramente non oscar ieri magma che ci
sono già un addio che come quella cosa
orribile succedendo stato quelli che
stile anna le onde del suo rumore forse
per gli spiriti niente fa il suono si ma
sono le sirene sulla testa di questo
mamma mia che brutta ci si vedono si
vede lo scheletro e poi tipo un mantello
con dei fili addosso questa è forse la
versione più brut e inquietante di craig
i rem preferisco 3d rincasa martino che
questa grelli orribile non voglio
muovermi adesso perché so che mi sta
cercando vedi semi mondo puo essere che
mi prendo assunti come fa vederti tutto
senza dalla testa siriana tipo solo di
non allestire nella tratta è quella di
garelli questi così qua forse la salma
che aveva acceso perché i gremi fava
sound soprattutto siren non va in corto
circuito che mi sono nascosta dentro la
macchina vedi lì la dietro allo studio
caduta
a casa non riesco diventato re è troppo
strana questa versione di greco in casa
che non va salendo le scale piano piano
vabbè poi con calma 6 ingressi io stavo
lavando via roma
la piccola che brutta non si muove più
dai tale del cal e brigati anche perché
noi siamo bloccati qui in gara su quello
l'unico accesso ai grammy sbrigati rubra
forse devo rientrare nella macchina che
un brutta sembra di fare in termini di
ritorni terni retrogradi guardarci sono
anche dei fili su costi e gli mancano le
sirene però ha deciso di rimanere lì
immobile io che faccio allora qui
possiamo tirare qualcosa in testa tipo
non è anche si sposta attente prende la
rincorsa spingi la lunghezza e funziona
ok non interagisce molto serio in tre
anni
com'è possibile che non mi fa niente
scudo avanti a lei
ok non ho messo la modalità fantasma o
massero modalità facile vorrete che per
la dentiera
vabbè chacha stare gremi addio
ok continua a evitare che si ricorra a
tutti i passaggi
io non mi ricordo mai tanto è rimasto
bloccato lì forse in un bug del gioco
che sarebbe grendi rimane bloccato nelle
scale non lo sappiamo
il campanello vediamo se ora fa iren
treni arriva se rimane quello della
massa bloccare la linea delle scale sta
contemplando ma non mi attaccasse era
rimasta di finire ma bloccata sulle
scandali stavamo così proprio di fronte
dello stato di qualche brano comunque
questo era siren grammy che voto gli
diamo io gli do un 7 perché era il
divertente vedere i gremi stoccata che
si muovevano allentatore tutta strana
pre non c'è davvero sembra che niente
quindi abbiamo avuto un figlio ed è
uscito quel modo scriveteci nei commenti
quali di zoomarine i quattro giochi cui
abbiamo giocato di fake granny preferite
il mio preferito era quello con il nonno
e la nonna era maturo bene disegni erano
molto bene il vostro preferito quale
scrivetecelo nei commenti lasciate un
bel mi piace e ora vi lasciamo a quattro
case linea di pubblicare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
buona visione